[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar applying whole genome sequencing
to define and predict antimicrobial
resistance i am marie stone of
labyrinths and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by opgen
to learn more visit
optigen.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
trish simner phd associate professor of
pathology johns hopkins university
school of medicine and director of the
medical bacteriology and infectious
disease sequencing laboratories johns
hopkins hospital
dr simner you may now begin your
presentation
thanks so much for the kind introduction
so this afternoon we're going to be
discussing using whole genome sequencing
for prediction of antimicrobial
resistance
here are my disclosures i do have a
pertinent disclosure for this
presentation i am a consultant for
opt-gen for which i will be presenting
research with aerosgenetics today which
is a subsidiary of op gen
so the objectives for today are to
describe how whole genome sequencing can
be used to define mechanisms of
antimicrobial resistance
understand the advantages and
disadvantages of using whole genome
sequencing to predict antimicrobial
resistance compared to phenotypic
antimicrobial susceptibility testing and
discuss the status of applying whole
genome sequencing to predict phenotypic
asp for clinical care
so the threat of antimicrobial
resistance is one of the biggest global
public health threats that we're
currently faced with
it is recognized by many international
body bodies as a priority to address
as it's a leading cause of death
worldwide where its highest burden is in
resource limited settings
despite understanding that it's a
leading cause of death the precise
magnitude is not well understood the
most recent estimates on um
mortality associated with antimicrobial
resistance was just published in lansing
in january of this year
where they estimated in 2019 that there
were 4.95 million deaths associated with
antimicrobial resistance and within
those and
within them there was 1.27 million
deaths attributed specifically to
bacterial antimicrobial resistant
infections
and so global collective action is
required to address this threat and two
of the initiatives that have been
described to address
the threat of antimicrobial resistance
include improving global surveillance
for antimicrobial resistance and
promoting new rapid diagnostics to
reduce unnecessary use of antimicrobials
both of which can be addressed through
whole genome sequencing applications
which i will discuss throughout my
presentation
so the standard method for clinical
laboratories worldwide to detect
antimicrobial resistance is through the
standard identification and
antimicrobial susceptibility testing
methods
on average these methods take between
two to three days where we collect a
specimen in the lab we'll plate it to
appropriate media
from there
we will isolate the organism on the
following day after
overnight incubation
we will perform multi-top mass
spectrometry for identification of that
organism and if we have pure and
sufficient growth we'll set up
additional our antimicrobial
susceptibility testing panels
the following day our standard ast panel
results will be available
and if we encounter a multi-drug
resistant organism we may need to set up
additional antimicrobials or send out to
a send out lab if
testing modalities are not available
within that lab further delaying those
antimicrobial susceptibility testing
results
furthermore if you're dealing with a
messy culture this might be this might
delay
the turnaround time or dealing with a
more fastidious organism that might be
have a slower growth rate
this may result in longer turnaround
times
luckily throughout the last decade and
we've seen the introduction of many new
tools that can help us more rapidly
detect antimicrobial resistance in the
lab these can include simplex or
multiplex pcr panels that can be
performed directly from the clinical
specimen or from cultured isolate
recovery of that cultured isolate in on
solid media
alternatively there are rapid phenotypic
methods that can be applied whether that
be chromogenic agars or
rapid phenotypic tests like the pvp2a
test that can be performed from culture
growth of staph aureus to predict
whether the organism is methicillin
resistant or susceptible based off of
the pvp2a assay
furthermore we started to see the
introduction of rapid phenotypic
comprehensive ast panels that can be
performed from positive blood cultures
that allow us to more rapidly detect
the phenotype using
novel methods for detection like digital
microscopy or microbial weighing to more
rapidly discern that phenotype than
visible growth
in addition to these methods
and most uh we're starting to see the
introduction of whole genome sequencing
to predict phenotypic ast
the advantages of whole genome
sequencing is that we are starting to
see the methods become more rapid and
can become can be used in a clinically
relevant timeline as well as it as it
detects this comprehensive
phenotypic it has the potential to uh
to detect a comprehensive phenotype
so what is whole genome sequencing well
it's an application of next generation
sequencing where you're sequencing the
genome of a pathogen of interest and you
can you'll sequence and sometimes just
taking the reeds or you'll assemble it
and from that those reeds or that
assembly you'll then detect
antimicrobial resistance genes
associated with that organism and all
the antimicrobial resistance genes or
single nucleotide variants associated
with resistance is referred to as the
resistance of that organism
you can then use that resistome or the
entire genome of your organism to define
mechanisms or resistance or to predict
your phenotypic antimicrobial
susceptibility
and resistance phenotype
and so that's what we'll be discussing
today so we're going to go over these
two applications of whole genome
sequencing for detection of
antimicrobial resistance
so the first we're going to the first
item we're going to address is using
whole genome sequencing to decipher
mechanisms of antimicrobial resistance
and to do this we're going to do it by
through a case presentation so this is a
35 year old woman living in the united
arab emirates who was on a flight to the
united states to seek medical care for a
relapse of her leukemia
during the flight
she became febrile tachycardic and
experienced lower abdominal pain
in the emergency department a blood
culture was obtained and she was
promptly started on cefepime
however her hospital course was
complicated as a urine culture on day
one and
imaging revealed multiple
intra-abdominal abscesses that were
drained and both the urine and intro
intra-abdominal abscess grew the
following e coli with the the uh mult
with this multi-drug resistant uh
phenotype where it only remains
susceptible to amacasin and gentamicin
based off of this profile and the fact
that it was resistant to both ertapen
and maripenum we would set up the carba5
assay to try to discern
what is the mechanism-mediating
carbipenum-resistance
resistance in this isolate and it was
found to be an ndm-producing e coli
when we see these complex or these
multi-drug resistant phenotypes in the
lab we then start to release additional
agents or cascade report additional
agents on our on our panels as well as
set up additional antimicrobial
susceptibility testing to try to guide
therapy and in this case um this isolate
was resistant also resistant to the
novel beta-lactam beta-lactamase
inhibitors like ceftazide mavibactem
veropenum vaporbactem and immepenum real
bactem all consistent with this being an
ndm producing e coli it did however
retain susceptibility to sofiter call as
well as minocycline and tigocycline
and so the patient um was uh
transitioned to sofiter call therapy on
day three once these ast results were
available to the clinical team and
chemotherapy was initiated on the same
day
so what is sofiter call um you might be
asking so civilical is a novel sitter
for conjugated cephalosporin that uses
this trojan horse approach to gain entry
into the bacteria so the cedar fork
component will bind free iron and once
that iron is bound to the agent it can
then use iron transporters for entry
into the cell once it once it's across
the outer membrane it disassociates from
the iron molecule and binds its target
pbp3 disrupting cell wall synthesis
the unique thing about suffider call is
that it has broad activity against
multi-drug resistant gram-negative
organisms including metallobeta
lactamases like our mdm producing e coli
so the patient unfortunately developed
new fevers on day 17
and tiger cyclin was added to the
sophidor call at that point
and on day 22 a urine culture revealed
two morphologies of e coli after 19 days
of sofidorocal exposure and the first
morphology demonstrated a slightly
elevated mic to sofiter call
as well as minocycline however the
second morphology um demonstrated frank
resistance to survivor call as well as
minocycline and tigercyclin
so while on suffider call and tiger
cyclone therapy the patient further um
we further recover the same second
morphology listed here from the blood
culture isolate of this patient
so the question that came up was what is
the mechanism mediating resistance so
we've seen the development of resistance
to suffider call well on therapy in this
patient and so we used whole genome
sequencing
using both long read and short read
sequencing approaches so we use the long
read approach to allow us to get um
closed whole genome and plasmid
assemblies and we used the short read
aluminum sequencing to to help us kind
of proofread the longer
reads generated from nanopore sequencing
because they have a higher error rate
than does illumina so it allows the
alumina reads allows us to kind of
proofread
our assemblies and so we generated these
hybrid assemblies
for the five isolates and
demonstrated that and performed whole
genome sequencing um and then
demonstrated that all isolates belong to
sequence type 167
and all isolates also contain this
multi-replicon plasma inc f plasmid that
at a minimum harbored one copy of the
ndm5 gene
however we did see increasing
mobilization of the element harboring
ndm5 within that plasmid from up to
five copies in isolate number four so
that was our second morphology from the
second urine culture and then up to ten
copies in the last isolate that we
recovered from the patient's blood and
the number of ndm copies correlated with
the increasing sophistical suffider call
mic's that we were observing clinically
so we have this association with
increased coffee number uh and
increasing suffider call mics
so to prove that um
that the increased copy number was
associated with uh sofiter call mics we
did the increasing suffider call mics we
did additional
studies including expression studies
where we demonstrated uh increased
expression up to two to four fold
expression in the in the isolates with
five and ten copies of the nvm5 gene
furthermore we demonstrated it
phenotypically that
that we can inhibit the increased
increased resistance by inhibiting the
ndm gene
and we did this by using a divalent
chelator edta
and
metallobetalactomises like ndm requires
zinc at their active site for activity
so if you chelate zinc
and divalent cations then the ndm will
no longer have activity and so for each
isolate we set down a subfitter called
disk with and without edta and you can
see for the first three isolates where
we have only a single copy of the gene
we don't see any or very little effect
of adding
edta to that disc whereas in isolate
four and five we start to see expansion
and opening of that subfider call
zone diameter consistent with when we
inhibit the ndm we see restored activity
of this of sephideracal
and further supporting
this association that this increased
copy number ndm5 led to increased
expression and leading to spitter call
resistance
however the
larger question still remains is is this
increased copy number the only thing
driving this increased resistance that
we were seeing clinically
so we've studied mechanisms of suffider
call resistance in my lab through
various different studies and on this
slide you'll see sofiter called depicted
here in these light blue circles and
when it accumulates to the iron on the
left-hand side of the slide it will then
allow for entry through the iron
transporter
of the fitter call into the periplasmic
base where it will disassociate from the
iron molecule and then be able to bind
the green pvp3 depicted here and
disrupt cell wall synthesis
however what we found through various
studies either looking at baselines of
federal call resistance so this is
resistance before the agent was even
available clinically among multi-drug
resistant gram negatives
as well as
additional studies such as the one i'm
presenting here with the development
during therapy
and other case reports is that we found
that there are various different
mechanisms that can mediate the fitter
call resistance including
mutations within iron transporter genes
the increased expression or modification
of beta-lactamases so this case is an
example of increasing the expression of
that beta-lactamase
to then
provide resistance or elevated mic's
cystofythericol
we've also seen modification of apse
among inducible app c beta lactamases
leading to resistance
with both entropactor chloeki and
pseudomonas originosa
additionally there's been descriptions
of
mutations in
um
the component of the inner membrane
protein complex providing energy to
tonve dependent transporters like iron
transporters which can lead to elevated
sufficient resistance
or in
the two-component transcriptional
regulators that have been reported to
affect the expression of iron
transporters so in this case we wanted
to look further to see if there was any
other
potential mechanisms that we had
previously seen
contributing to the resistance that
we've seen develop in this patient case
and so we did variant mapping against
isolt 1. so isolate 1 was our first
index isolate with a single copy of ndm5
where our cipher call mic was still
sitting at two and then we took all
consecutive isolates um that we
recovered from the patient after that
and compared it to the index islet to
see if we can find any consistent
mutations
or
our additional mutations leading to
resistance in these isolates
and
there was no consistent mutations we did
see a mutation in mc um
consistent with what we had seen in the
past but it was but it wasn't present in
isolate four where we were we were
already seeing frank resistance at an
mic of 32
so we concluded that these additional
mutations likely contributed a minor
role to the resistance that we were
seeing in these ice in the development
of resistance that we observed in this
case um
however it shows you how you can use
whole genome sequencing especially in
these cases in the progressive
development of resistance to try to
to define
additional
single nucleotide variants leading to
resistance
so ultimately in this case we ended up
using the combination of ceftazine
avibactam and as tree and m for therapy
for this patient where um
metallobetalactinases do not hydrolyze
as tree and m however in this case um
there was additional beta-lactamases
being produced that was resulting in
estrogen resistance so that avibactam
would inhibit those beta-lactamases
restoring that activity as tree and am
and we were able to show in vitro
either by a synergy synergy method and
by a um
mic-based method that we can
that we predicted that this combination
would be susceptible in this case
and um that was what we ended up
treating this patient with successfully
um and the patient is doing well to date
so this is a case where we were able to
demonstrate how we can use whole genome
sequencing to define mechanisms of
resistance
and so how can we relay that information
into
predicting the phenotypic ast
of applying whole genome sequencing to
predict phenotypic ast results
so what are the pros and cons of using a
whole genome sequencing approach to
predict ast well let's start out with
our conventional phenotypic ast methods
we know this is a highly standardized
growth-based method that determines what
concentration of a drug inhibits the
growth of the bug and it's interpreted
using clinical breakpoints that have
been established for each drug bug
combination using mic distributions
pharmacokinetic and pharmacodynamic data
as well as clinical outcome outcomes
data the pros to using our conventional
phenotypic methods is that they're
highly standardized our physicians are
experienced and confident and reliant on
those results
these methods are relatively cheap and
the great majority of laboratories
especially catholic credit laboratories
within the u.s and internationally
greater than 90 percent
use automated methods for determining a
phenotypic ast profile
the cons to this are that they are slow
you know as we've shown in the
as i've shown initially that it can take
two if not days if not longer for the
physicians uh to get that est profile to
try to help taylor therapy
and furthermore there's little to no
amr mechanism information that is gained
from the phenotype
whereas with whole genome sequencing to
predict the phenotypic ast we're using
the resistome or the entire genome of an
organism to predict antimicrobial
susceptibility and resistance using a
molecular method and in this case we're
using next generation sequencing
the pros to this approach is that it has
the potential to be more rapid there are
some sequencing methods like nanopore
sequencing where you can analyze your
data in real time and can allow for a
more appropriate or a more clinically
relevant turnaround time
it also has the ability to identify
antimicrobial resistance and we can
interpret those results in the context
of the phenotypic ast as susceptible or
resistant so so that the clinicians are
used to the results that we might be
generating using this novel method
and last and most important is that the
information that we gain from whole
genome sequencing not only can be used
to predict phenotypic asd but it can be
used for many other purposes
like
strain typing for outbreak
investigations looking at virulence
factors for prediction of
clinical associations
etc so there are many different
applications to the data being generated
that we can use
clinically the whole genome sequencing
data for not just for predicting
phenotypic ast
the cons to this though is that it's not
as standardized there are some complex
interpretations and results may vary
based on analysis pipeline and our
database is used
it's expensive especially if you're
comparing it to the phenotypic ast
methods these methods are a lot more
complex and are than our methods that
we're using currently and right now
there's really no outcome studies
demonstrating the clinical utility of
whole genome sequencing ast to predict
the phenotype
but luckily what we've seen in the
literature today is that
whole genome sequencing to predict asd
has pretty good accuracy
um and here's just a
a summary of some of the studies that
were performed
and most of these initial studies
performed were performed with the slower
but more accurate alumina sequencing so
illumina has shorter
accurate high accuracy reads but the
sequencing run needs to uh has a circuit
certain sequencing time where the
sequencing run needs to be complete
before you can analyze those results and
in general in these initial studies they
were running from 24 to 48 hours before
it can even be
analyzed and that does not take into
consideration the upfront wet lab work
most of these studies focus on one
particular pathogen with mostly manual
curation for predictions
and the studies varied by the methods
the sample size the antimicrobial agents
evaluated however what these studies do
show us is that there is a potential to
use apply whole genome sequencing to
predict asd because the great majority
of this studies demonstrate greater than
90 sensitivity and greater than 95
specificity
however
the process for whole genome sequencing
to predict asd is quite long and complex
as i mentioned where you might take
a pure culture isolate from a solid
media plate alternatively you might want
to do some sort of liquid culture or
inoculum-based approach um like we're
starting to see from positive blood
cultures like the sepsi type or approach
etc um you could take that that biomass
pure biomass of your organism of
interest you have to prepare your
sequencing library load your flow cell
start the sequencing run and start to
collect your data then you're going to
detect your amr genes and then predict
your susceptibility profile
so the problem with this from a clinical
aspect is that the methods are complex
and the turnaround time can be too long
depending on the mechanic
methods applied
the prediction models are still being
developed and as i mentioned previously
they're often developed for only a
particular one organism of focus and not
a broad spectrum of organisms
and we the third is that we need simple
and automated tools to generate these
predictions
because we don't have the time in the
lab to do these manual curations of
which some of these research studies are
applying
so how do we address these issues well
we can address the methods
by
finding methods to more rapidly
uh set up sequencing but as well as
interpret our sequencing results
and so what's available in the
literature about
interpreting
or applying whole genome sequencing to
impact patient care or therapeutic
decisions
so i'd like to reference this one study
by shelburne and others in cid it's from
2017 but it really was the first
feasibility study where they used whole
genome sequencing to predict empiric
therapy for neutropenic fever patients
and so they used whole genome sequencing
of 90 gram negative bacilli including
enterobacteralis as well as pseudomonas
to predict the phenotype for pipercillin
the carbopenum cefepime and septazidine
and they took these isolates from
bloodstream infections of neutropenic
cancer patients
they sequenced the isolates on the mysqq
and they did manual curation to
determine the presence or absence of
acquired antimicrobial resistance genes
as well as detections of of mutations
that can lead to resistance to these
beta lactams and overall they found a
sensitivity of 87 and specificity of 98
and so this study really demonstrated
the feasibility of using whole genome
sequencing to guide antibiotic treatment
decisions for patients with
life-threatening infections for an array
of medically important gram-negative
pathogens
so what we wanted to do in our lab was
address the time the turnaround time so
in that study they were using illumina
they were it was
a retrospective study they did manual
curation so it took so retrospectively
they were saying could they apply this
data but
technically it still was not within a
time frame that would be clinically
relevant
however we know with nanopore sequencing
the long read sequencing
the advantage of long reads i
highlighted earlier from a whole genome
sequencing perspective is that you can
get enclosed genomes and plasmids but
also it allows us for real-time
sequencing analysis so as we start the
sequencing run we could already start to
analyze the data being produced unlike
the illumina which requires you for your
sequencing run to be complete and so
this has a benefit of being able to
detect antimicrobial resistance genes
quite rapidly and we've previously shown
in another study that within 2.3 minutes
of starting a sequencing run we could
detect kpc in a kpc producer
and so in this study we wanted to see if
we can
use whole genome sequencing or this
real-time whole genome sequencing
approach using nanopore to optimize
antimicrobial therapy for
multi-drug resistant ground negative
infections specifically for
carbopenem-resistant
organisms and in this study we focused
on klebsiella pneumoniae and included 28
carbapenem resistant klebsiella anemone
19 of which were carbopenemys producers
and nine of which were non-carbopenomes
producers
including 12 carbapenem susceptible
isolates
and so what we did is we sequenced these
isolate on the minion sequencer
and took two different approaches to
analysis
and the reason why we did this is one of
the major pitfalls to nanopore
sequencing is that it has a higher air
rate and that air rate becomes really
becomes relevant when you're trying to
predict single nucleotide polymorphisms
leading to resistance so we took these
two separate
analysis approaches from the data
generated from nanopore to see how
accurate our predictions could be for
phenotypic ast the first approach is
what we call the real-time analysis
approach where we just took the
sequencing reads coming off the nanopore
and map them against a resistance
database
which is the card database using
the aunt arma
tools that are available with nanopore
sequencing
and with our methods we can from isolate
to
two results we can get results within
eight hour turnaround turnaround time so
making it relevant to clinical care and
more rapid to phenotypic ast where in
general you'll still need that overnight
growth or 24 hours before you get those
results we also took
an approach to an assembly-based
approach where
we tried to assemble the genome using
consensus to try to correct for some of
those errors that we know are more error
prone with nanopore but also applied
some bioinformatic tools like nanopolish
and additional tools to try to correct
those errors to get a better prediction
especially for those single nucleotide
polymorphisms however with those that
initial
bioinformatics in the background it
added 14 hours to our turnaround time
however overall we did show that
these
approaches did pretty well compared to
our reference broth micro dilution ast
results not surprisingly the real time
approach
only gave us 75 overall agreement and
you'll see that the agents that um our
meat resistance is mediated by single
polymor single nucleotide polymorphisms
like the fluoroquinolone ciprofloxacin
or levofloxacin here only had 30 percent
agreement and that's because that was
the real-time approach where we weren't
trying to correct for some of the
nanopore errors when we took the
assembly approach we've seen a lot
better agreement at 91 and started to
see better agreement for even predicting
some of those uh single nucleotide
variants leading to resistance and so
showing us that even though there's a
higher error rate with nanopore you can
use bioinformatics tools to kind of
overcome that air rate to allow us to
apply this methodology to make a
difference clinically where we can have
these results in a clinically applicable
time so here's just showing what the
standard turnaround time would be from a
blood culture with our phenotypic asts
where if you're dealing with a
multi-drug resistant gram negative like
these carbopenem-resistant klebsiella
pneumonia in the study sometimes it took
up to 72 hours before final
antimicrobial susceptibility results
were reported whereas with the nanopore
real-time approach we could have results
within 31 hours or the assembly approach
within 36 hours
so the logical next question was
could we have an impact on patient care
if the clinicians had those results to
them within that 31 or 36 hours as we're
estimating in the previous slide so we
did this hypothetical trial design to
evaluate time to effective therapy and
so of the 28 there were 28 patients with
carbopeneum resistant klebsiella
pneumonia infections
22 received inadequate empiric therapy
and the median time to effect effective
therapy for conventional antimicrobial
susceptibility results was 61 hours
whereas if we would have applied our
rapid whole genome sequencing approach
to prediction we had the potential to
impact 20 of those patients with a
median time to effective therapy of 41
hours with the real time approach or 35
hours with the assembly approach
and you might be asking well why is the
assembly approach quicker than the
real-time approach well
when we said the turnaround time of the
the laboratory methods were longer with
the assembly approach the reason is is
that the assembly approach provided more
comprehensive data to infer the ast
activity than the real-time approach for
which there were delays on awaiting
additional asps
so here we have
two proof of concept studies showing
that we can apply whole genome
sequencing ast methods to potentially
impact patient care
but how do we predict those phenotypes
well it's really not all that
straightforward and there are really two
different approaches that have been
applied in the literature and at its
essence we're trying to predict
susceptibility or resistance of an
antimicrobial for a specific bug the
most common approach that has been
applied are these rule-based approaches
where you use curated databases of amr
loci or snips and then you use
then you try to find amr genes or k-mers
from your data using those databases
using either raw reads or assembled
genomes
but that's the first step the first step
is identifying
the amr gene the second step is then to
predict it which is not always very
straightforward
you need to correlate that gene or snip
to a phenotype
and it will vary by organism
expression the interplay between
multiple mechanisms and by antimicrobial
agent
the second approach is this model based
approach which we're starting to see
more publications on which uses machine
learning or statistical approaches where
you can link the entire genome or
specific markers to an mic or a
susceptible resistant result for each
antibiotic and train the models to try
to predict those
those results the mic or the susceptible
or resistant result
these models have the ability to predict
mic's with no a priori information about
the underlying gene content or resistant
phenotypes of the strain so the models
really do that in the background to pick
out them for important information
for those predictions
so the the next step is once you've
predicted it you're going to have to
compare to um the phenotypic reference
standard which is broth micro dilution
because the intended use
of whole genome sequencing is to predict
your phenotypic ast so you need to
compare it to your reference standards
and many of these initial studies that i
quoted
throughout this presentation
especially that initial slide where i
compared a bunch of them they were using
non-reference ast methods as their
comparator however if we really want to
get this methodology through the fda
we're going to require the same they're
going to require the same standards as
traditional phenotypic methods where
you're going to need to compare to a
reference broth micro dilution method as
well as get
assess your results in terms of
categorical agreement are you
getting the correct susceptible or
resistance
categories and then also further looking
at the types of errors you're
encountering are they major errors where
you're detecting
you're calling something falsely
resistant and you have to keep those
below three percent or very major errors
which are the the errors that scare me
the most when you're calling something
falsely susceptible when they're indeed
resistant and um the fda requirements
there are less than
1.5 percent um in terms of so we're so
we're having we're going to have to
fit or have our predictions be within
these similar expectations to what we
have with phenotypic asps the other
problem is is that the method that we're
comparing to the phenotypic reference
standard is an imperfect standard itself
where the standard dilution is plus or
one
plus or minus one doubling dilution so i
show at the bottom of the screen here
the mic is read where you see visible
inhibition of growth here at 0.5 but if
you repeated this in triplicate you
might within the standard error asc
might get a result of 0.255 or 1
and this can vary significantly more
depending on the organism or
antimicrobial agent combination for
instance with pipa cylinder bactam and
pseudomonas originosa the variability
can be much larger just within the
standard air of ast testing
furthermore and so this variability is
really not accounted for in the clinical
setting as it's not practical for us to
perform replicate mic tests for clinical
care
and so these prescribed methods are uh
highly standardized from inoculum
density media temperature atmosphere and
incubation period the phenotypic methods
which really do not reflect the
variation of the environment and
expression of phenotypes that can occur
during clinical infection so really what
we need to do is also look at getting
doing some clinical outcome studies to
look at the value of wgs ast predictions
in terms of clinical outcomes and
patients
and so hopefully we'll start to see some
of those studies coming down the
pipeline
so getting back to our prediction
pipeline our prediction methods
so the initial rule-based approaches
that were applied by many of the studies
um
apply a bun many assumptions to the data
first is that there's a single genetic
locus that's responsible for the
phenotype or if multiple loci are
present
they do not interact
uh second is that these loci are highly
penetrant and are not affected by the
strained background and they're the
third is that there's this complete
knowledge of the genetic basis for that
particular phenotype which we know is
not true and we know that the the
methods mechanisms mediating resistance
can be complex just as i explained in
that first case that we had that there
are heterogeneous mechanisms that can
result in suffider call resistance for
example
and so
what um our
what the model based approaches attempt
to do are these studies attempt to
capture that uncertainty
in the genetic basis of resistance and
reduce overfitting of that data using a
variety of statistical modeling and
machine learning approaches as i've
highlighted in the red box here
the good thing about these model based
approaches is that the accuracy seems to
be really well and excitingly we could
see um the ability to predict the
minimum inhibitory concentration or the
mic within plus or minus one doubling
dilution which is amazing and that's
what we would expect within the standard
error of phenotypic asps
so the next
step that we need is so we're addressing
methods
we're addressing predictions of the
phenotype the next is that we need
simple
analysis tools especially for
introduction to clinical microbiology
labs
to help for patient care because we
really don't have the bioinformatics
expertise nor do we have the time to do
some of these manual curations and so
what we're starting to see are these
fully automated analytic programs that
are suitable for use in clinical
microbiology being introduced
i list three here the next gen
diagnostics 1928 diagnostics and
aerosgenetics where the first two
have been applied and published in the
literature on applying these rule-based
tamer analysis tools
specifically to staphylococcus species
whereas some of the aeros genetic
studies and some of the studies that
i've been able to collaborate with them
with which i'll go over in a few slides
we've started to look at a variety of
organisms and it uses the stack ensemble
models and rule-based analysis
using the eris database
and so we'll go into that a little bit
further
but here's one of the publications um
comparing next-gen diagnostics and the
1928
analytics programs for 102 staff aureus
isolates recovered from positive blood
cultures to try to predict the
phenotypic profile for these isolates
including these agents listed here there
are some differences in which
one of the the analytics could predict
some but not all of the agents and hence
the difference in the combination
of and isolate antibiotic combinations
that can be compared between these two
pipelines but overall it was really
import encouraging to see a high
concordance
between the predictions and the
phenotypic ast results where there is um
100 percent agreement with oxycontin
vancomycin and mu poryson for all three
for these pipelines but you do see that
there were some discordance results that
occurred and that if you look at the
error rates associated with those
discordant results they would be outside
of what would be acceptable for a ft fda
cleared
assay that being said this study really
showed that these automated
bioinformatics tools may be useful for a
clinically amenable workflow to predict
the genotype
to predict sorry
both phenotypic susceptibility and
resistance and staph aureus
now this study these studies have been
applying alumina based technologies and
what uh we wanted to do in our research
lab is see can these analytics handle um
nanopore based data because nanoforce
data nanopore based data can be produced
as we said in real time you know can has
the potential to be available to impact
patient care however what i find most of
the time is that some of these programs
are developed specifically for illumina
data and cannot be directly applied to
nanopore data so um what we did in
collaboration with aeris genetics is
took 144 of our klebsiella pneumoniae
including carbopenemies and
non-carbopytamines producing as well as
carbopenem-susceptible isolates and as
you recall in my research lab we do that
hybrid assembly so we have both alumina
and nanopore sequencing results for all
of our isolates to help us with genome
assembly to define resistance as well as
mechanisms of spread etc but we use this
data here to assess how the pipeline
would do with illumina data on its own
and with nanopore data on its own and so
we use aeros genetics cloud pipeline uh
compared to broth micro dilution and
created 1982 comparisons between the
predicted and observed resistance
phenotypes for 19 antimicrobials
and what was really exciting is that we
found predictive um asd demonstrated
comparable results for both nanopore and
illumina data which is exciting because
again although the nanopore data has a
higher air rate it looks like some of
our bioinformatics tools and analysis
pipelines can help us overcome that and
allow us to kind of use these tools for
prediction
for real time in the clinical setting
where an overall agreement that we've
seen with
89 for illumina uh for categorical
agreement versus 88 for nanopore so very
comparable uh but we also evidently saw
better performance with our
carbopenemies producing organisms at 95
and 96 categorical agreement
and it was slightly lower with our are
significantly lower for our
non-carbopytamine producers and that's
because it could be more difficult to
predict carbapenem resistance in the
absence of that acquired gene of
acquired resistance gene but we have
been working
along with our heiress collaborators to
further uh tweak
the ability to define um carbapenem
resistance among those known
carbopenemies producers
the other thing that comes up is that
we're now starting to see treatment
guidelines based on whether mechanisms
of resistance testing is performed or
not and these treatment guidelines uh
recommend therapy
the recommended therapy will differ
based off of the mechanism mediating
resistance so for example if your
phenotype is third generation
cephalosporin resistance
you don't know based off of the
phenotype whether that's mediated by
esbl or app c that being said if you
knew the mechanism mediating resistance
um the recommended treatment would
differ where with espl meropenem would
be
the recommended therapy versus absi
cefine so not only understanding the
phenotype but knowing the mechanism
needing mediating that phenotype can be
helpful and the same with carbapenemies
producers were based off of whether it's
a
producer or not and the genotype the
recommended therapy will vary so we've
been working with eris again to try to
merge the predictive ast and that
genotypic
information to try to more accurately
guide therapy
and
we recently put this data together um
looking at the combination of predictive
ast and genotypic information among a
group of enterobacteriaceae so expanding
past the klebsiella pneumonia that we
had focused on before and applying it to
e coli other klebsiella species
enterobacter chloeki
um and so here in the study we were able
to demonstrate the accuracy of the aeris
genetics pipeline for prediction using
both illumina and nanopore sequencing
for with a broader cytogram negative
bacilli but also the um this overall
accuracy of 93 versus 91
with the by combining these two
approaches um which will have the
potential to further help guide
therapeutic management of patients
the last study i'm going to highlight
here is a study again that applies the
errors genetic database to a wide
variety of gram negatives as well as
staph aureus
to predict ast and you can see here that
overall
the categorical agreement varied by
organism as well as antimicrobial agent
but showing that we can apply these
pipelines
more broadly to potentially
be applicable for patient care and i
guess the last question that we have so
we're working through
the methods the predictions um the
analysis is that the last thing is well
how do we report these results
appropriately to positively impact
patient care
for in general these results that we've
been approaching it by as susceptible
and resistant categories um and grouping
the intermediate with the resistant
category however the question comes up
are we confident enough to predict
susceptibility
you know like i said earlier my the the
error that i'm more most worried about
is a very major error where we're
telling a clinician that this uh isolate
is susceptible when in fact it's
resistant so is there a different
wording or a softening of the wording
that we could potentially put in our
reports uh prior to the phenotypic asts
being available
and then
there's also discussions about whether
you could put accuracy estimates or
reliability scores around these results
to kind of
guide the clinicians in terms of the
expectation of how accurate those
predictions are
so what do we need at this point to more
broadly apply
whole genome sequencing to predict ast
in the clinical microbiology lab i've
kind of went over these a little bit
already but again just to reiterate more
rapid turnaround times simplified
workflows with reduced hands-on time
this organism to sequencing robotics
robotics or microfluidics
it looks like next-gen diagnostics are
working on some sort of microfluidics
to apply for strain typing purposes for
whole genome sequencing but you could
technically apply that same type of
method for hold for predicting asd
we need more cost-effective approaches
and
this is being done
through both nanopore and aluminum
nanopore has a flangle that's you know
only 90 for the flow cell so we're
coming into a more relevant cost
analysis compared to some of you know
the broad molecular panels that we might
implement in the lab
or from the lumina side they have
different sequencers now like the iseq
and the mini seek that can allow for
more rapid sequencing times
and then we need tools that can will
convert that live streaming data
and we need working groups to discuss
the best methods to convey those results
as well as outcome studies to determine
the clinical accuracy and impact to
patient care if we were to start to
apply this
clinically
so in summary whole genome sequencing
allows us to define mechanisms of
resistance and to detect all
antimicrobial resistance genes harbored
by an isolate
also known as the resistome
whole genome sequencing predictions has
been demonstrated as an accurate tool to
define and predict resistance among a
variety of organisms
improvements around methods turnaround
time prediction methods and automated
analytic tools are bringing us closer to
implementing whole genome sequencing to
predict asd in clinical labs and these
automated analytic tools are being
adapted for use with both illumina or
nanopore data
which is great such as was shown with
the research that i summarized here with
aeris genetics
and there's still but there's still some
work ahead before these assays can be
fda cleared for clinical use uh where
there needs to be further consideration
on reporting and uh clinical outcome
studies are required
so thank you so much for your attention
um and for listening to me today if you
have any questions feel free to reach
out to me otherwise i'm happy to take
any questions
okay thank you dr simner for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for
so let's get started
our first question is two parts
any idea why cefederical resistance is
mainly seen with ndm producers and not
other mbl producers and how exactly did
you notice the multiple copies of ndm5
thank you for the questions and thank
you everyone for listening in it's great
to see the global audience asking some
questions so
um hi everyone uh so to answer the
questions um the first question is is
that i think some of our ndm producers
have uh some hydrolysis rate
baseline hydrolysis rates of ndm
um and maybe uh the reason why we're
seeing
some resistance among indium producers
but more specifically i think it might
come down to the specific allele what
we've seen in our lab is ndm5 like in
the case i presented uh tends to possess
enhanced carbapenemy's activity and so
i think not only is it just ndm but also
the allele might become important when
thinking about
suffider call resistance and ndm
producers
and in terms of how did we determine the
copy number as i mentioned we used both
long read and short read sequencing
methodologies where the long reads allow
us to actually
kind of close the loop on those plasmids
and sequence the entire plasmid and we
could see with sufficient coverage and
multi
multi-locus sequence alignment that
we were indeed seeing uh increased copy
numbers within those plasmids in the
later um
isolates after the patient had been on
sevitor call therapy
thank you
next question
what are your thoughts in terms of the
possibility of discovering alternatives
to novel drugs for example repurposing
existing drugs by combining them in
novel ways to preserve the last resort
drugs
that's a good question so i think there
you know there's two things here right
um what can how can we use the data that
we
get from whole genome sequencing
and understanding mechanisms of
resistance to discover alternatives or
new drugs you know we can try to devise
new agents that can overcome some of the
resistance mechanisms
that we're defining through whole genome
sequencing and further defining through
functional studies
um
the second
question is you know the second part of
that is you know there's certainly
studies now looking at repurposing older
agents
for example phosphomycin you know
traditionally thought as a urinary drug
is now
being approved for iv formulation i
think mostly outside of the u.s for now
uh so our european uh colleagues might
be seeing that where you know it's an
older drug that they're trying to
utilize now and may have activity
against mdr gram negatives
or in the example of our case
where you know the combination of two
approved agents may be able to overcome
uh the mechanisms mediating resistance
such as estrea and m combined with
septazity mavibactam and i know that um
the combination of as tree and m
avibactem itself
is undergoing further clinical trials
currently so again
looking at learning the mechanisms can
help us understand how we can reuse um
you know repurpose some agents that we
uh might just otherwise disregard just
based off of the phenotype where we can
combine them or revisit their use for
other purposes
or
or use that data or that information to
try to
create
a new method new agents to overcome
those mechanisms
thank you
next question
you showed a comparison of several
automated analytics and pipelines how
are these technologies different and
what differentiates rs genetics
yeah i think first off i don't have uh
too much experience with other analytic
pipelines other than eris genetics as i
um highlighted in the slide there um and
so most of my information in regard to
the 1918 diagnostics and the next gen
diagnostics are what's published in the
literature and uh what they have
published on their websites um
but the two things that kind of stand
out on what's available currently in the
literature about these methods
is one is that
to my understanding to date most of the
publications on 1918
diagnostics and the next-gen diagnostics
have only applied illumina data and the
publications have focused mostly on
staff species or even more specifically
on staph aureus
whereas um with the eris pipeline and
you know again with some of our research
and collaboration with eris is that we
found that we can apply that pipeline
with
comparable accuracies with both illumina
and nanopore data but also
we're starting to broaden application to
a broader range of drug bug combination
so a broader range of organisms to um
not just be focused on a single pathogen
so um that is what i'm aware of so far
based off of the literature um
but um so those were would be the main
differences i would highlight
thank you
our next question has two parts
what are the pipelines that can be used
to predict args and its mechanisms from
pathogens
and can args be predicted for
meta-genomic sequences
yeah um i think there's so the pipeline
so there are many different databases
and programs out there that can just
easily detect antimicrobial resistance
genes right you know there's card
there's um
uh oh my gosh there's sophie but there's
many of them that are available um out
there and what those pipelines do are
simply detect the presence of a gene i
think the what we really need is not
only detection of resistance but
prediction of phenotype and so that's
where these um automated analytics like
the three i presented in this
presentation are helpful where it's not
just detecting the resistance gene or
associating resistance or the potential
of resistance these are actually being
developed to predict um the phenotype
and then in terms of metagenomic
sequencing
it's a little bit more difficult right
because you have um depending on the
source you might have a whole lot of
competition in the background you might
not be able to know who the gene belongs
to so i still think we're a little ways
out on um predicting um you know
phenotype based off of resistance genes
from metagenomics we can certainly
detect them but being able to predict
phenotype is a whole
other can of worms that are still being
developed
thank you next question can you please
comment on how is the rs technology
already used today in clinical routine
yeah i think um
so
in my opinion it's really still in the
research use only setting from what i
can tell
um i'm not sure if there's any other um
i haven't found any publications of them
really applying it clinically currently
that being said um you know ideally we
could start to
um
get those studies out there that um that
applies this in the clinic in the
clinical lab so that we can you know not
just hypothetically show its value but
show its value moving forward like
combining nanopore with um an automated
analytic like like aeris genetics
thank you
next question
was the cost analysis of wgs per colony
comparing with other methods performed
so we didn't do a cost analysis
currently in our studies however
i'm optimistic
that you know these costs are coming
down you know if we think about uh
nanopore and the flongol it's ninety
dollars uh for that flow cell and we can
start to get the reagents for you know a
whole genome sequencing a sequence down
comparable to some of the multiplex
molecular panels that we apply
um so i do
think that the costs are coming down and
whether you're able to multiplex these
would further help you reduce those
costs but and similarly with illumina
platforms we're starting to see these
smaller um sequencing platforms that
allow for more real-time or like shorter
sequencing runs
um but as well as reduced costs for the
the flow cells etc thank you
we have time for one more question
what do you see as the next steps which
disease states sample types pathogens
would you see the most utility in
for predictive ast
that's a great question and one of the
studies that we're currently working on
is
going looking at you know blood culture
isolates
right now we're starting to see the
introduction of kind of liquid inoculums
whether that be through a sepsi type or
other methods that are becoming
available so with blood culture the
advantage there is that most of the
times are monomicrobial and if you can
get sufficient biomass from that
positive blood culture um that would
allow us to you know even further reduce
that turnaround time in terms of
predictive ast and so um that's one
thing uh that we're planning to work on
a little bit further as our next study
and to kind of tie together some of the
other questions we're going to work on
using the flongle
try doing this more in real time
along with clinical care to assess you
know how well are we doing if we thought
about this in terms of workflow in the
lab as well as how well are we doing in
terms of cost comparison from you know
fte um standpoint and reagent standpoint
as well
okay so um so that's where we're going
with that no worries
well thank you again dr simner for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor opjen for underwriting
today's educational webcast before we go
i'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye
you